vamos a dar paso a andrés meza muñoz
ante la redacción de france 24 para
tomar el pulso a las redes sociales
andrés buenas noches adelante que se
dice en las redes sociales
buenas noches santiago como usted lo ha
dicho son las redes sociales el
escenario de estas constantes reacciones
mientras avanza el conteo de votos
vamos a ver precisamente el tuit del
presidente de donald trump que emitimos
hace un momento acerca de esta contienda
y dicen nuestros abogados han pedido un
acceso significativo pero de qué sirve
esto el daño ya se ha hecho a la
integridad de nuestro sistema y a la
propia elección presidencial esto es lo
que debería discutirse dice el
mandatario a medida que pide un recuento
en wisconsin que no se cuenten más votos
en michigan y que no se reciban más
papeletas en pensilvania uno de los más
incendiarios ha sido el hijo del
presidente donantes eric trump quien
dijo hemos ganado en pensilvania sin
embargo ahí como lo vemos en pantalla
twitter agregó un verificador de
contenido que dice que es posible que
las fuentes oficiales no hayan anunciado
los resultados cuando se tuiteó esto y
precisamente de pensilvania sigue bajo
escrutinio twitter y facebook han estado
escondiendo instalando verificadores de
contenido
a chrome ya su equipo que tratan de
deslegitimar la elección y esto como
parte de su política para combatir la
desinformación veamos ahora las
reacciones de la fórmula
vicepresidencial de joe biden kamala
harris quien junto a job aiden han
estado muy activos en redes sociales
respondiendo a los comentarios de trump
dijo anoche toma amenazó con ir a la
corte para evitar que se contarán todos
los votos pero nuestra campaña está
preparada para contra atacar sin embargo
el presidente el vicepresidente de mike
pence sólo se ha limitado a replicar
información con pedagogía electoral